Lo que vamos a hacer en este video es demostrar
que los ángulos son congruentes si y sólo si
tienen la misma medida, y para la definición
de congruencia usaremos la definición de
transformación rígida que nos dice que dos
figuras son congruentes si y sólo si existe
una serie de transformaciones rígidas que
mapea una figura en la otra. Ahora bien,
¿qué son las transformaciones rígidas? Las
transformaciones rígidas son transformaciones
que preservan la distancia entre los puntos
y la medida de los ángulos. Así que manos a
la obra. Empecemos con dos ángulos que son
congruentes y queremos demostrar que tienen
la misma medida, por lo tanto, empezaremos con
dos ángulos congruentes entre sí. Ahora bien,
según la definición de congruencia dada por
una transformación rígida esto significa que
existe una serie de transformaciones rígidas
que mapea el ángulo ABC en el ángulo DEF.
Y por la definición de transformaciones rígidas
se preserva la medida de los ángulos.
Así que, si somos capaces de mapear el ángulo
de la izquierda en el ángulo de la derecha con
transformaciones rígidas que preserven la medida
del ángulo, entonces los ángulos deben tener la
misma medida; por lo tanto, ya sabemos que la
medida del ángulo ABC es igual a la medida del
ángulo DEF, y con esto hemos demostrado este
enunciado verde en este sentido, es decir,
demostramos que los ángulos son congruentes si
tienen la misma medida. Ahora demostrémoslo en
el sentido inverso. Empecemos con la idea de
que la medida del ángulo ABC es igual a la
medida del ángulo DEF. Para demostrar que estos
ángulos son congruentes, mostraremos que siempre
existe una serie de transformaciones rígidas
para mapear el ángulo ABC en el ángulo DEF.
Para ayudarnos con esto, vamos a visualizar estos
ángulos. Voy a trazar este ángulo rápidamente:
este será el ángulo ABC -y recordemos: un ángulo
está definido por dos rayos que parten de un punto
en común, ese punto es el vértice-, entonces aquí
tenemos el ángulo ABC, y dibujemos el ángulo DEF,
se va a ver algo así, DEF. Y lo que haremos
ahora es realizar nuestra primera transformación
rígida. Primero trasladar el ángulo ABC de tal
forma que el punto B se mapee en el punto E.
Si hacemos esa traslación, el ángulo ABC se
va a ver algo así: el punto B está mapeado
en el punto E, y aquí es donde se mapea A y
por acá es donde se mapea C. Algunas veces
escucharás como notación A'C', y aquí es donde se
mapea B, entonces sería B'. Ahora, la siguiente
cosa que haremos es rotar el ángulo ABC sobre
su vértice, sobre B, de tal forma que el rayo
BC coincida con el rayo EF. Entonces rotaremos
todo el ángulo de esta forma para que ahora el
rayo BC coincida con el rayo EF. Y, bueno, tal
vez estés diciendo: "Oye, C no necesariamente cae
sobre F porque puede que estén a distancias
distintas del vértice". Y eso es cierto,
el rayo se puede definir por cualquier punto que
esté sobre él, pero si ahora hacemos esta rotación
y el rayo BC coincide con el rayo EF, entonces
estos dos rayos serán equivalentes, y dado que
la medida del ángulo ABC es igual a la medida del
ángulo DEF, entonces esto nos dice que el rayo BA
ahora coincide con el rayo ED. Y con esto hemos
realizado una serie de transformaciones rígidas
que siempre funcionan. Si primero trasladamos uno
de los ángulos, entonces sus vértices se mapean
uno en el otro; después, si rotamos hasta que
el rayo inferior de uno de los ángulos coincida
con el rayo inferior del otro ángulo, entonces
podemos afirmar que el rayo superior de los dos
ángulos también coincidirá, debido a que los dos
ángulos tienen la misma medida, y justo por esta
razón ahora los ángulos coinciden completamente.
Por lo tanto, ahora sabemos que el ángulo ABC
es congruente al ángulo DEF. Y hemos acabado,
hemos demostrado ambas partes de este enunciado:
si son congruentes tienen la misma medida y si
tienen la misma medida entonces son congruentes.